yes, basically we are
a non-profit association that has been
working with refugees for years and
normally we offer classic
social and asylum procedure advice
and help with housing will
have a clothing store and actually
holistic help for refugees
and socially disadvantaged people like this
emergency situation we can crisis but
2015 2016 already
done we will definitely do it first according to
need collect lists of goods that
are needed at the various hotspots in the
city in which we will get
called deadlines tomorrow and then deliver
as needed
and that's why we work  very dynamic
from day to day, from hour to hour,
some of the majority of our helpers
are actually refugees themselves who came in
2015/16 from iraqis
afghans syrians of
course also many people from the
city society in general but
our house has only been running with the refugees themselves for years